ils ont conservé leur titre acquis en
2017 les déstockeurs du collège louis
armand de savigny-le-temple en seine et
marne ont remporté les finales
ile-de-france des trophées de robotique
une victoire acquise au milieu de la
ville du futur les robots doivent réunir
des cubes de construction écologique
libéré l'eau potable amener l'eau usée
dans la station d'épuration différentes
tâches qui rapporte des points c'est
innover avec l'équipe chercher des
solutions pour réaliser des tâches qui
nous sont demandés
on va près
il est fabriqué tout le procédé pour
faire le robot élaborer une stratégie
pour 34 équipes d'île de france des
jeunes âgés de 7 à 18 ans des maisons de
quartier et des établissements scolaires
participent à ce projet pédagogique ils
ont eu six mois pour construire un robot
à partir d'un cahier des charges
alors c'est intéressant pour ces jeunes
parce que il est ils se servent de leurs
mains
il mène un projet de a à z puisqu'en
septembre il n'avait rien et maintenant
ils ont des robots totalement
fonctionnel et ça leur permet aussi de 2
travailler en équipe une autre équipe à
conserver son titre les montigny ecocity
ont remporté le prix éco citoyenneté
pour leurs maquettes sur la ville
écologique une installation composée
d'une serre d'une voiture électrique et
de deux éoliennes à les villes du futur
plan écologique avec moins d'émissions
de co2 ça se développe deux présents
tous aider l'économie et les voitures
aussi sans production
on voit de plus en plus de voitures
hybrides électriques
des supers engagé le projet leur a parlé
très très rapidement on est très
rapidement parti sur un projet un peu
s'il écolo parce que c'est ce qui nous a
c'est ce qui est ressorti un petit peu
des cahiers des charges et on a tous
pris ensemble l'idée de
de faire une maquette ce pouvoir
habiller nos semble la finale nationale
des trophées de robotique aura lieu le 7
et 8 avril prochains à saint quentin
dans le département de l'aisne